(mellow guitar music)
(air whooshes)
(metal squeaks)
- I grew up really--
- Really poor.
- My mom and I didn't really have much.
- One year in high school
was particularly hard.
- She was a single mom
and didn't make a lot of money.
- We weren't gonna make
much of that Christmas Eve
because there was not
much we could do with it.
- We sat down on Christmas Eve.
- To a very simple dinner.
- And we heard a knock at the door.
- It was a pastor from our
local church and his family.
- They were holding
boxes and boxes of food
that they had brought for us.
- Ham, egg nog, uh,
basically everything you need
for a Christmas dinner.
- They heard about our
situation through the grapevine
and put together a food drive
to give us a better Christmas.
- My mom and I just kinda
stood there in disbelief
and cried.
- And we're so shocked we couldn't speak
other than just to say thank you.
- They came in, sat everything
down, hugged us and left.
- I'll never forget the moment.
- I'll always remember the moment.
- We close the door.
- And cried.
- And just looked at each
other with tears in our eyes,
unable to say anything.
- Sometimes there's good
people in this world
and you just don't expect
them to come for you.
- And then we went to the kitchen
and started cooking what would be--
- The best Christmas dinner,
probably I've ever had.
- It would has to be the best Christmas
I've ever had.
(mellow guitar music)
(air whooshes)
(metal squeaks)